[Musique]
avez vous déjà remarqué à quel point les
mots sont puissants le pouvoir des mots
moi je suis aujourd'hui ici pour vous
dire qu'avec du coeur tout est possible
et je vous dis pas ça comme ça je me
suis pas levé ce matin en me disant
alors ce soir chez hothead x après ma
quimper qu'est ce que je vais bien
pouvoir le raconter le pouvoir des mots
tiens avec du coeur tout est possible ça
c'est bien ça fait classe
non je ne voudrais pas sorti ça comme ça
ça fait déjà plusieurs années que j'ai
éprouvé cette croyance positive que je
me suis construite que j'ai testé
re-tester s'est testé et approuvé
breveté sarah hébert je vous jure que ça
marche et pendant les dix-huit minutes
que j'ai avec vous je vais vous montrer
pourquoi comment et en sortant on vous
allez pouvoir tester en vrai alors en
fait les mots sont puissants et surtout
quand quelqu'un si ça vous est déjà
arrivé vous encourage à rentrer dans un
projet peut-être qu'un jour vous a dit
ah ouais les coptes ont une idée tu
devrais y aller c'est bien moi
aujourd'hui
j'attends plus cette personne parce que
des fois on attend longtemps
alors du coup j'ai décidé que cette
personne là ça pouvait être moi donc je
m'appelle tard à ça maintenant devait
avoir compris j'ai grandi sur un voilier
pendant onze années de ma vie en famille
voilà là c'est sur l'écran moi et mon
frère en notre vie à poil c'était trop
bien au soleil les fesses à l'air
fouettés par les embruns les poissons
les dauphins on a grandi comme ça
pendant onze années dans l'océan
pacifique et l'océan indien
ensuite j'ai décidé de me lancer à fond
dans la planche à voile et puis j'ai
fait onze années de carrière
professionnelle et sportive en planche à
voile et puis un jour j'ai voulu
traverser l'atlantique en planche à
voile et ce projet là vous imaginez bien
que c'est un projet quand même juste
énorme et qui avant d'avoir d'abord
avant de pouvoir en parler
g
j'ai mis du temps c'était un rêve un
doux rêve que j'entretenais à
l'intérieur mais josé vraiment pas en
parler autour de moi j'avais honte honte
d'avoir un rêve aussi cros si grand
j'entendais déjà les gens qui allaient
me dire non mais sarah tu délires
l'atlantique je sais pas si tu te rends
compte l'atlantique d'un planche à voile
tu as beau être championne et à un
moment donné c'est pareil c'est pas
possible quoi et puis bon entre nous
avec ton défibrillateurs cardiaques
implantables autant autant dire que
c'est carrément irraisonnables oui parce
que ça se voit pas comme ça mais en fait
dans la salle vous avez une femme
bionique avec vous là dans ma poitrine
gauche j'ai un petit défibrillateur qui
est mon ange gardien qui me surveille au
quotidien et tout ça c'est pas fait
forcément facilement j'ai le sourire
aujourd'hui mais ça a été quand même des
épreuves
c'était le 1er mars 2006 je me suis
réveillé mes yeux était à peine
entrouvert j'ai tourné la tête à droite
et hélas il y avait cette espèce de gars
qui étaient recouverts de ce temps avec
un énorme bandage et puis d'un coup j'ai
réalisé j'ai compris que je sortais du
bloc la trachée complètement serré un
poids énorme dans le coeur et c'est mon
défibrillateur qui avaient pris place
dans mon bus que rectorales et et là
j'ai compris qu'il allait falloir que
j'apprenne à vivre avec ce corps
étranger ça allait devenir mon allié mon
ange gardien
donc j'ai je me suis fait à cette idée
là et puis
très rapidement j'ai commencé à discuter
avec les médecins et les médecins m'ont
dit voilà maintenant on vous a réparé
vous pouvez continuer votre vie enfin ce
serait quand même bien que vous arrêtiez
d'aller sur l'eau même ouais si vous
pouviez juste vivre à terre ce serait
mieux
chouette mademoiselle hébert à faire sur
la terre des trucs de des trucs d'autres
trucs que sur l'eau moi j'ai du mal à
les concevoir mais c'est vrai qu'à plein
de choses à faire
alors faut que je vous explique mon lien
viscéral avec la mer donc là c'est moi
ya pas longtemps sur notre bateau et ça
se voit pas comme ça parce qu il est 6
heures du mat et qu'on s'est levé super
tôt pour repasser la barre d'étel mais
je suis heureuse mais je ne peux pas
être plus heureuse que ça je veux pas
être plus heureuse que ça en fait il
faut imaginer que moi mon kiff total
qu'elle me retrouver sur cette grande
étendue bleue et puis de re de me
retourner
partout partout partout bien vérifier
parce que des fois la terre ge se cache
derrière une vague fluo que lot et une
fois que j'ai tout scruté par tous et
qui a que du bleu alors là c'est le
nirvana
vraiment je me sens chez moi juste à ma
place c'est ça qui est chouette avec la
nature et l'océan c'est que elle vous
remet juste à votre place et moi c'est
ce que j'aime que ce soit en planche à
voile que ce soit en bateau
en fait ce qui est vraiment agréable que
d'avoir le vent dans les embruns le lot
qui vous faut être ses sensations de
vitesse vous êtes vraiment libre sur le
enfin c'est vraiment pour ça que je bats
j'ai grandi sur l'eau je continue à
passer mon temps sur l'eau donc autant
vous dire que quand les médecins ont dit
sarah il va falloir arrêter d'aller sur
l'eau j'ai pas compris
j'ai pas compris parce qu'il m'avait mis
un défibrillateur pour que je puisse
continuer à vivre et puis d'un coup il
me disait en gros ben non en fait
c'était une blague
tu vois continue ton coeur va continuer
à battre mais toi tu vas pas vivre en
fait
du coup j'ai voulu savoir si ma passion
l'emporté pas sur la raison donc j'ai
commencé à faire des petites recherches
suis allé rencontrer différents rythmes
all your ride monologue est cardiologue
en france pour savoir si c'était trop
déraisonnable c'est quelle était la part
de risque et puis j'ai fait une moyenne
parce que vous imaginez bien qu'il y en
a qui étaient là-bas dans le côté
précaution attention faut pas y aller
c'est dangereux
et puis d'autres qui étaient un peu plus
moyen je fais ma moyenne et surtout en
fait j'ai écouté mon coeur j'ai écouté
mes sensations
j'ai fait confiance à mon corps en fait
j'ai vraiment je me suis vraiment
questionné sur ce que j'avais envie de
continuer à faire de ma vie ce qui me
faisait le plus vibrer et je me suis dis
surtout que la vie nous apporte des
difficultés mais qu'on peut toujours
s'adapter et c'est là que
je me suis souvenu de mon éducation de
ma mère qui me disait par exemple tu
sais sarah l'essentiel dans la vie c'est
d'en profiter
et je vous jure que ça aide d'avoir eu
des parents comme ça une enfance comme
je les aime parce que parce que j'ai
pensé à tout ça c c ou c mois qui ont
suivi et du coup je suis retourné sur
l'eau deux mois un mois après j'avais le
droit de recommencer le sport
l'entraînement et deux mois après mon
entraîneur m'a dit écoute sarah vient
avec nous on va au championnat d'europe
je t'ai inscrits et tu vas voir ça va
être génial
j'avais encore mal au muscle pectoral et
je lui ai dit mais tu es su j'y suis
allé et j'ai gagné j'ai gagné
championnat d'europe
autant vous dire que pour moi c'est la
plus belle victoire que j'ai eue de
toute ma carrière
derrière c'est pas pour me la péter
derrière j'ai été vice championne du
monde mais ce goût de cette victoire sur
le championnat d'europe c'était quelque
chose d'unique pour moi c'était la
preuve qu'avec du coeur tout est
possible derrière je me suis repris une
claque
la fédération française de voile m'a
retiré ma licence du coup j'ai perdu la
médiatisation française j'ai perdu mes
sponsors français et j'ai dû regarder
ray mais je me suis dit finalement le
plus dur a été fait maintenant c'est que
de la paperasse et des chats qu'à signer
ça devrait être gérable et donc je vous
disais que je vais traverser
l'atlantique et heureusement un jour
j'ai eu le cran le culot l'audace d'en
parler en fait et ça s'est fait de façon
totalement
hasardeuse enfin oui c'était le hasard
total j'étais au travail je travaillais
on s'en fout d'ailleurs je trouvais
total bref mon patron était là et je
discute avec lui c'était dans le monde
de la voile de l'audiovisuel dont qu'ils
avaient quand même ce que c'était que
l'atlantique et les routeurs donc ça
veut dire qu'il fait les trajets météo
pour les gens qui font des courses au
large donc vraiment il sait ce que ça
veut dire que l'atlantique
et puis on buvait notre petite ella et
puis je dis oui tu sais moi je je je
j'ai un projet j'aimerais traverser
l'atlantique en planche à voile
donc je vais vous le faire parce qu'en
fait je m'attendais pas du tout à cette
réaction
le gars m'a regardé et m'a dit mais
c'est super qu'est ce que tu attends je
m'attendais pas du tout à ça je me suis
retrouvé en mode flac et je me suis dit
mais oui qu'est ce que j'attends ça fait
déjà trois ans que j'ai cette idée
qu'est ce que j'attends donc c'est parti
dans ma tête c'est j'ai tout tout tout
construit je me suis dit bon alors il va
falloir un bateau il va falloir une
équipe à terre une équipe en mer
qu'est-ce que je prends comme équipement
où je m'entraîne
qu'est ce que je mange qu'est ce que je
vois il faut que je trouve des sous
combien ça va coûter marre du coup il
faut que je fasse un dossier de
sponsoring les sponsors ils sont souvent
à paris alors c'est parti pour paris le
train etc
la machine était lancée ça m'a mis deux
ans je pensais qu'en un an j'allais y
arriver
bionic mais pas super moumen les gros
projets apprennent à être humble plus
humble que ce qu'il le faut et et bref
au bout de deux ans je me suis retrouvé
sur cette plage de dakar au sénégal avec
ma planche prête à me lancer vers la
grande bleue
et ça c'était vraiment un des plus forts
moments de ma vie
un des plus fort moment de la vie parce
que vous voyez comme sur la photo là
j'allais vivre ça
j'allais vivre ce rêve que j'avais
vraiment portais en moi qui étais
vraiment dans mon coeur depuis des
années alors c'est vrai que que j'ai
soit arrivée ou pas arriver en fait on
s'en fout ça franchement bien de dire ça
parce que je suis pas arrivé mais en
fait si et j'ai mis longtemps elle
comprend qu'en fait si j'étais arrivé
alors je vous explique pourquoi j'ai
navigué pendant plus de la moitié du
parcours pendant 12 jours six à sept
heures par jour j'ai fait sens 150 km
par jour juste avec mes bras sont ma
planche à voile et mon petit
défibrillateur qui surveiller que tout
le monde allait bien là dedans et et
surtout j'ai vécu des choses de dunks
jeudi une baleine sauter devant moi deux
reprises j'ai vu des sceaux de dorade
coryphène des milliers de nuages de
poissons volants argenté au matin doré
au soir en fonction de la lumière du
soleil c'était juste magnifique faut en
fait comprendre que j'étais seul parce
que j'avais beau avoir un catamaran qui
me suivait en fait il perdait de vue au
bout d'une demi heure
parce que les vagues sont grosses les
photos rendent jamais assez mais vous
sur claivaz qu'il était très grosse et
donc il me perdais de vue donc je
faisais ma petite vie peinard moi sur ma
planche quand j'avais navigué pendant
quatre heures et je commençais à plus
long terme et doigts de pied je
m'arrêter je mangeais ma pomme et les
petites barres de céréales et je
repartais et puis bon les conditions
météo on était quand même très très
difficile le vent n'était pas orientée
de façon à ce que j'arrive à en
guadeloupe et j'ai dû arrêter
j'ai dû arrêter alors que c'est vrai que
sur la carte n'était plus si loin
ça l'était quand même avec le vent dans
la mauvaise direction ça l'était quand
même et de devoir prendre cette décision
d'arrêter cette traversée ça n'a pas été
simple ça a été vraiment quelque chose
de douloureux parce que j'avais trois
objectifs sur cette traversée est en
fait il y en a un qui a pas été relevé
mais
le premier pour moi le véritable
objectif c'était vivre l'aventuré du
grand large avec ma planche à voile et
sa gelée vécu pleinement et il ya que
moi qui l' ai vécu et c'était vraiment
unique
très peu de gens alors vite pourront
vivre vivre ça c'était vraiment très
fort comme un astronaute sur la lune
la deuxième chose c'est le truc qui a
raté c'était que je partais de dakar et
je devais arriver en guadeloupe ça je
suis pas arrivé donc c'était nul
voyez vous allez le dire nulles ben oui
je suis arrivé derrière pendant quatre
mois je me trouvais nul à chier
c'était naze je n'étais pas arrivé
c'était un échec
et au fur et à mesure je découvrais ce
que c'est qu'une petite dépression
quatre mois je sais pas si ces petits
mots heureusement ça n'a pas duré trop
longtemps et il m'a fallu du temps pour
comprendre en fait que déjà j'avais vécu
mon rêve et qu'en plus dans mes trois
objectifs
j'en avais deux j'avais réalisé et pas
des moindres parce que le troisième
objectif pour moi c'était de montrer
qu'avec du coeur tout est possible
c'était de montrer que malgré mon
défibrillateur on peut encore s'adapter
et continuer de réaliser ses rêves et
ses projets et j'ai reçu des milliers de
de tweed message de facebook de deux
mails que j'ai lu bien plus tard et que
j'ai pu entendre et écouter bien plus
tard grâce à la méditer médiatisation
aussi que j'ai réussi à avoir et ça pour
moi c'était fort de montres de voir que
juste avec ma petite expérience
personnelle moi c'était traverser
l'atlantique
il y en a ce sera à faire autre chose
que j'ai pu être véhicules de porteurs
de ce message positif c'était vraiment
très fort donc au final
en fait c'est marrant pendant longtemps
les jambes demandé et est-ce que tu va
retraverser est-ce que tu va réessayer
cette traversée de l'atlantique
oui non et pendant longtemps j'ai pas
trop quoi dire parce que je me disais
ouais c'est vrai c'est bête faudrait
peut-être que j'y retourne pour vraiment
clôturer le truc est en fait non non non
ça fait déjà un moment que je réponds
non j'y retournerais pas parce que j'ai
vécu ce que j'avais
vivre je voulais tout seul je voulais
parler de ceux de ce message et le train
positif est en fait moi je compte pas en
mille les kilomètres nautique
je compte pas en mille mais je compte en
baleines en dorade coryphène en soleil
levant sur la mer enfin en infinie bleus
en nuances de bleu c'est comme ça que je
compte je prends les 1000 pour moi
n'avait plus autant de valeur et puis il
ya tellement de trucs à faire d'ailleurs
pu tout à l'heure je suis dans seront là
et je vous dis mais comment je vais
faire pour rester encore quelques
minutes là dedans là c'est un peu et
soufflant et 20 klaus toorop le met mais
il ya tellement d'autres trucs à faire
et d'ailleurs avec du coeur tout est
possible ça continue pour moi puisque
non je n'ai pas mangé trop de chou fleur
je suis enceinte et et c'est vrai
qu'avec ce petit être qui poussent sans
moi j'aimerais vraiment je ne sais pas
si la voile la planche à voile
s'il aime la mer ci sera sportive ou pas
du tout mais ce que j'aimerais vraiment
c'est qu'il soit convaincu qu'avec du
coeur c'est-à-dire avec de la passion de
la motivation
alex qui vous fait vraiment vibrer du
travail aussi la persévérance tout était
possible mais vraiment tout il n'y a pas
de reste trop grand trop beau trop
non il faut pas avoir honte de ses
pensées de ses rêves de ses ambitions
j'espère qu'il se donnera vraiment
aucune limite pour vivre sa vie
pleinement et s'épanouir en tout cas
nous ses parents on s'en donne pas
puisque j'ai la chance d'avoir un
amoureux qui me suit et puis qui est
surtout emparé du projet parce que
maintenant c'est un projet à deux on
parents nés en mai 2017 avec un bébé qui
aura quatre mois pour un tour du monde
en voilier rejoindre la nouvelle
calédonie et puis notre but c'est d'en
profiter
ça a bien fonctionné à lui répété
plusieurs fois comme ça et lui aussi il
le sera et vous vous qu'est ce qui vous
fait vibrer et a forcément quelque chose
qui vraiment vous transporte un truc
quand vous le faites vous vous dites oh
punaise mais ce truc là mais il faudrait
que je le refasse tout le temps tous les
jours pourquoi je n'étais pas souvent ou
quand est ce que là quand est ce que
quand est ce qu est la dernière fois
vous vous êtes auto censure est ce que
vous vous êtes dit y'a pas longtemps ce
truc génial j'ai vraiment envie de le
faire et si je le disais ah ouais non
mais non mais par contre tendance est
trop grand et trop beau c'est trop
génial non non non vraiment je peux pas
mais arrêtez arrêtez là tout de suite
maintenant arrêter ou plutôt commencer à
partir de maintenant
dès que vous allez sortir de ce thé
d'aix s'il vous plaît prenez votre petit
cahier mettez tout ce que vous aimez
tout ce qui vous fait vibrer autorisez
vous soyez vraiment l'artiste de votre
vie tout vous est possible
le plus important c'est de le vouloir et
histoire d'être sûr que vous l'avez
vraiment compris avec du coeur tout est
possible
[Applaudissements]